à 39 ans Steve roche ne pouvait imaginer
que sa bursite et son infection
streptocoque à la gorge allait se
transformer en fasciste nécrosante connu
sous le nom de bactéries mangeuse de
chair assez violente et après ça là sans
rien avec des tremblements
à respirer mal au cœur et là tout ça
c'est dégradé très très rapidement après
trois opérations et 6 jours à l'hôpital
son bras gauche a été sauvé
les muscles donc les heures étaient
comptés carolan Doucet a aussi survécu à
la maladie causée par la bactérie
streptocoque du groupe a j'ai paniqué je
te drague ma plus grosse panique ça a
été la première opération parce que ils
m'ont fait signer un papier comme quoi
que il pouvait me couper le bras juste
ici mais attention ce n'est pas toutes
les bactéries strictoque a qui vont
donner des infections invasives et
conduire à la bactérie mangeuse de chair
qui entre autres frappé l'ex Premier
ministre moitié Bouchard dans la grande
majorité des cas elle peut mener à
d’importants maux de gorge ou à une
surinfection ou de plaies souligne un
docteur Cécile Tremblay fête
beaucoup de la population n'est portable
de cette bactérie là puis il a plus
souvent elle ne sait aucun retard mais
quand elle trouve sa place dans un
endroit un petit peu plus fragile elle
va donner des infections qui parfois
peut être des infections sévères entre
ou 2022 et février dernier 347 cas
d'infections ont été déclarés au Québec
contre 223 cas en moyenne entre 2015 et
2019 ce qui représente une hausse de
55%. il faut donc rester à l'affût en
cas de douleur extrême sans signe
physique apparent
reste que le lavage de main s'avère l'un
des meilleurs moyens pour prévenir les
infections à streptocoque A aujourd'hui
j'ai gagné parce que j'ai toujours le
l'usage de mon bras ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal